there's a reflexive Instinct by some to
say this isn't this whole Kanye thing
it's not about anti-Semitism it's about
mental illness he says he's not taking
the pills that a Jewish doctor told him
to take this is mental illness plain and
simple and it's really important not to
see these things as either or or one or
the other there's lots of mental illness
and mentally ill individuals who have
good or bad ideas who have inclusive or
discriminatory ideas and also there is
anti-Semitism and other types of racism
and xenophobia that has nothing to do
with mental illness or it might overlap
with it and one of the other concerns
when you talk about seeing in seeing
people as individuals and evaluating the
things they say you don't have to ignore
the content of what they say because
there may be a mental illness component
and that's another thing that is
unfortunately being used by some to sort
of not necessarily excuse but diminish
the importance of the content of what
Kanye has been saying